today we bring you everlasting who looks
good no I'm sure people are treated Jose
how do you guys feel that the
Bachelorette is a little pissed off
about the show they're doing fine the
show's been on for twenty seasons
they've got like 16 million viewers
watching my heart's not breaking for
them it feels like it pulled the veil
back
I think we've pulled the veil back on
reality television just in terms of like
how is the how're these shows produced
but I don't really think at least my
intention was not to go out there and do
some sort of expose and like take this
huge ABC franchise down like I I enjoy
The Bachelor
this is unreal you look amazing you
watch listen when I was single and like
looking for love I would watch that show
being like what does love look like how
do you fall in love I was like studying
The Bachelor like I want to get explain
to me how this happens this is what I'm
like spending my life doing so I
understand the fascination with it but
now with two kids and like all the stuff
going on I don't have as much time but I
understand just from that lines JoJo's
having a thing and there was a whole
thing a fantasy suite and I get it I
don't think they were really damaging
the bachelor by any means
how do you play crazy so well yourselves
like it is kind of exhausting I feel
like we've just finished shooting about
six weeks ago or so and I'm just
starting to come back to it I mean my
character was thrown into a psych ward
it's pretty it takes there's no effort
no shake it's at all the twists and
turns have been incredible this season
yeah it's it I mean every script you're
reading and you're like whoa how are we
gonna pull that off and you know you're
the job of the actor is really to
deliver to the best of your ability the
story that is presented to you and so
the job this season has really been to
just connect an emotional through line
and I really just try to paint the
picture of Rachel being a real survivor
and I feel like you know I'm proud of
the work that was put out there but you
never know if Rachel like if she's this
close to just it's gonna she gonna bring
oh is she gonna break it all so what's
going on behind those eyes she has those
eyes that she's like glazed over yeah
she's fighting in her brain with what's
going what she's doing and saying yeah I
feel like she's not one of those
characters that has like a confidant you
don't really listen to her express
herself and so a lot of the dialogue is
going on inside of her head and so for
the episode that I actually directed the
season I try to do as much as I could so
the audience could feel this sort of
chaos and the manic that she lives with
inside of her how has it been directing
and acting it to say it's got it I mean
talk about manic but no I mean it was
really just incredible I've been working
and acting since I was three years old -
so finally have the opportunity to say
this is how I read it this is how I
imagined it and to bring that to life
was just so exciting did you pack your
meds are you seriously gonna pretend
that you care about me now
Constance is your girl it shows it shows
whatever explain your relationship with
concen
the very first episode we shot I was
like the real love story of this show is
between the two of us so from like day
one we were committed to that and we
have just been like incredible partners
LM also the wonderful thing is that
we're both like my working mothers and
it's a very challenging thing in the
sense that we shoot in Vancouver like
our families are all over the place and
she's further along in the parenting
game than I am so having her to sit down
and be like listen I'm feeling a lot of
Gilks I'm not there or whatever the
issue is and having her to turn to and
be like a sounding board and someone
that's incredibly reassuring and he's a
wonderful mother but to have that that
sort of camaraderie and this experience
hasn't been incredible and invaluable
you have two small children well two
small children so how was it shooting
and having two small ones
well my small one for two months when I
went back to work so it was um it was
seeing how much you could sort of uh
manage at one time I can't really manage
a two-month-old there's no managing
there's not a lot going on the director
on set came up with a a code for me for
breastfeeding cuz like that guy's 1027
I'll be back in 15 because you know
talking about breastfeeding I'm sad
surrounded by all these men we don't
want to know what's going on with like
10 1037 I'll see you in 15 thank you
you guys yeah I have a lot of crazy
storylines can we just go through a
couple of them really good go okay who's
gonna end up running Michelle I mean
probably clean it might is a Rachel but
let's be honest is probably going it's
we're gonna have a baby at some point I
mean could you imagine Quinn being a
mother the kid would be well dressed
will the bachelor ever play football
again oh Darius yes it's really a
question I really don't even know if I
know the answer to that oh really they
don't even know I'm fake I can't
remember okay okay will uh will the
right girl went out in the end yes
really
if you and I have the same opinion on
who the right girl is we know the right
girl is gone but I'm just saying
and what about season 3 where do you go
from here where do you go I I have the
exact same
I mean you broke ground with an
african-american bachelor you've had you
had a shooting you have reporters behind
the scenes you have older women wanting
babies you have a catatonic guy I was
good they were dealing with mania
bipolar disorder tons of things and so
where does the story go from here where
does it go it's I feel the exact same
way I think we like to call it in
Hollywood it's a WP was a writer problem
I really have no idea where the show
goes I mean I think there's plenty of
options quite honestly I think that like
we could do the you know ado everlasting
with a male suitor we could do
everlasting with a female contestant we
could go on and do a totally different
reality show I think really at the heart
of the show it's about these two women
who are very good at their jobs who are
conflicted because their morals are in
opposition to what their jobs are and so
wherever we go I think that's really
going to continue to be the focus of the
show I'm going to call the writers right
after this and see what they've got
cookin for season three